my name is Lars moravi I'm the vice
president of vehicle engineering at
Tesla Motors a lot of people love
Crossovers and they love crossovers for
the right reasons there's a lot of
storage there's a lot of utility and I
think what we wanted to try to do when
we made the model y was sort of take
that notion and just blow it up
our cars have always had great range and
great dynamic in the mobile why we
actually added what we call off-road
mode
which is a little bit of that break
torque vectoring to like on steroids
maybe you're doing a little bit of river
rocking and one wheel gets off the
ground we clamp that down and the other
three put torque forward so you still
keep moving and that's something gives
the model y a capability that you might
not otherwise get in pretty sporty
crossover SUV
but at Tesla we always started a first
principles approach you don't get to say
well we've done that for 50 years so
that's the way we're going to do it for
the next 50. you have to prove
everything you're doing from the ground
up with you know first principles of
physics and mechanics and and really
that's our boundary is like what does
physics say is the envelope and that
that's as far as we'll take things
there's been a lot of talk about the
rear casting and how cool it is and what
it does but one of the problems when you
make big pieces of aluminum is that they
warp when you heat treat them but with
model y we actually invented our own
alloy that is able to achieve super high
levels of strength and durability so
that saves money costs energy because we
don't have to heat treat it with these
giant ovens but more importantly keeps
the part straight and that means we
don't have to machine the whole thing
from an engineering geek out standpoint
that's like one of the coolest parts of
the thing is like yeah you can look at
it and say okay they replace the 100
Parts with one or two but really that
the alloy and the material developed on
that was super special because we
wouldn't have been able to do that
without it
at Tesla we've always tried to
constantly improve our products then to
integrate all the functionality that you
have in a typical crossover is something
that's super important so the cargo
space in the rear the additional cargo
space in the front
fold flat seats that give you this wide
open area if you need to do it the
towing that we have on the back end all
of that combined and then saying you
know what it's still going to be a Tesla
when you drive it people that like to be
dynamic they're going to love it people
that want to sit up high and see the
road they're going to love it people
that have a family and need the storage
space they're going to love it every car
we build every new product we make I
want to take it a step further I want to
make people's understanding of what an
EV can be and what a product is make it
a part of your life a part of your
experience ultimately it results in a
product people love and that's when you
know you've hit the right point of
vehicle engineering
[Music]
foreign